the nation's economy appears to be
getting stronger the labor department
reported on friday that employers added
943
000 jobs to their payrolls last month
that brought the nation's unemployment
rate
down to 5.4 percent the lowest level
since the start of the pandemic last
year
but that's still 5.7 million fewer jobs
than february 2020. wall street closed
higher
on the stronger than expected jobs
report on capitol hill congress is
expected to hold another rare saturday
session today on the infrastructure bill
with more on that christina raffini
joins us now from the white house
christina good morning
good morning dana well as infrastructure
week stretches into infrastructure month
and what i've decided to call hot gravel
summer
the president left for wilmington this
weekend without a bill to sign on his
desk
and now it's unclear if that
infrastructure measure alone
will be enough what is
indisputable now is this the biden plan
is working
president biden argued yesterday the
positive jobs numbers 943
000 added last month are proof positive
the country
is moving in the right direction once
this bill passes the senate
i know that body will move toward
establishing the framework
for the remainder of my build back
better agenda
that bill of course is the senate's 1.2
trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure plan
but the president also wants lawmakers
to pass a separate
multi-trillion dollar democratic budget
bill the president tends to sign each of
them into law
states are already eyeing the much
needed repair funds they could get if
the bill passes
including 25.3 billion dollars to fix
california highways 537 million for
bridges in texas
and 316 million for public
transportation in hawaii
whatever you can achieve in a bipartisan
way
bravo on friday speaker of the house
nancy pelosi applauded the
infrastructure bill's
forward momentum but was unclear if she
would call the house back from summer
recess
without the budget bill in tow we hope
that it will have
passed soon but at the same time we're
not going forward with leaving people
behind
now as you can hear behind me probably
the white house crews have taken
advantage of the president's absence to
do some infrastructure of their own
you mentioned the senate is in session
today they're going to hold the vote
this afternoon that will kind of show
them
if they get the 60 votes to move the
measure along the bill can probably go
all the way
but we'll have to see what the house
does and if they decide to come back for
a vote on that measure alone
or if they want to wait to see what
happens with that larger budget bill
michelle a lot of eyes on that one
christina thank you so much